a gente veio atender esse pedido à
é um prazer participar do df
se fazer o alívio cômico não quer dizer
musical pra trazer um pouco da
rapidamente assim dessa nossa história
dessa trajetória do nenhum de nós nós o
tonho pra quem não sabe irmão daninha
ele é nosso empresário o nosso a gente
chama de 5º bituruna mas na verdade é um
cara que está com a gente desde o início
do nenhum de nós vão aí mais de 30 anos
eo nenhum de nós que é formado então
como disse por cinco caras essas cinco
caras estão juntos há mais de 25 anos o
veículo junto com a gente e joão vicente
são relações duradouras e que tem uma
base sólida na amizade nos valores que a
gente tem que são valores que nos dizem
muito que nos falam muito o coração ao
nosso trabalho valores associados à
caráter ética com essas coisas que a
gente valorize sem as quais a gente não
vai adiante
a gente jamais chegaria neste tempo todo
de estrada com um de nós se a gente não
precisasse por isso e nós todos
trabalhando com uma coisa que difícil no
brasil é trabalhar com arte já que a
gente sabe que por exemplo tem o mesmo
empresário uma coisa rara
tem muito picareta para a gente sabe o
tom é um cara que é referência no brasil
e para o tapete e ea gente tem isso como
uma coisa que nos serve de norte a
trabalhar para continuar trabalhando são
a gente lança agora no 18º dia 5 três
dvds mais de 2 mil shows sem nunca
deixar de fazer shows ou deixar de bater
seu público sem nunca deixar de
trabalhar que é um exemplo que a gente
mesmo mais do que com o nosso público
para as pessoas
nós deixamos ele deixar como um legado
para os nossos filhos e os próximos
países a gente tem isso muito arraigado
também daquelas coisas que nos faz andar
de cabeça erguida por aí porque a gente
sabe que construiu
a carreira baseada em valores muito
legais importantes para todo mundo então
se vocês quiserem cantar junto a gente
vai fazer um par de temas aqui porque
hoje o negócio mais falado que cantava a
gente a cantar um pouquinho
quero cantar junto não
deixa o papel só ligar que fosse bardem
que fosse uma saída
deixamos pra depois
a troca de carinho e deixamos que a
rotina fosse nosso caminho
nem em sonhos pra depois a busca de
abrigo
deixamos de nos ver fazendo algum
sentido
[Música]
ano
nenê nunca
a cama
[Música]
acham se sentindo melhor a gente sentia
em que trazia a dor ao nosso dia a dia
deixamos de dizer o que a gente dizia
deixamos de levar em conta a alegria de
lixo
os dedos a chance de manter
unidas nossas vida
[Música]
é nóis lugar
mas o mais forte
[Música]
hum
a 1
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o time daqui a dias alguma coisa boa
tarde
é uma honra ter recebido o convite da
ana ea gente ter podido estar aqui fim
de semana normalmente é complicado com
nenhum de nós
há 30 anos a gente sacrifica os nossos
finais de semana fazendo coisa que ele
mais ama na vida que é tocar e falar pra
gente que gosta de ouvir que é o caso
hoje aqui além de gostar de ouvir e
gostar de cantar então a gente mais
próximo agora como é um breve momento
então essa é a nossa idéia era né
essa canção ela era um fenômeno na nossa
história porque desde a primeira vez que
a gente tocou ao vivo e não nós não
havíamos gravado essa música ela causa
um impacto muito forte no nosso público
e hoje é engraçado porque a gente às
vezes não têm noção dessas coisas
se a gente for olhar o spotify ele tem
as execuções de uma certa maneira se
mede as canções que mais se gosta né ii
essa canção ela a primeira astronauta de
mármore um sucesso nenhum ea segunda que
poderia pensar que a camila que é o que
teve mais execuções é essa música que a
gente vai tocar agora se chama você vai
lembrar de mim
[Música]
a banda eu te vejo espera eu beijo não
sinto vergonha atenas desejo minha boca
basta me tua boca de treme
meu sonho é um fecho mas os meus estão
em aberto
o mundo tem em si não deu certo
eu achei que nós chegamos tão perto mas
agora é com certeza eu enxergo
e no fim eu amei por nós dois dos seus
mais você
[Música]
gil da sua bona eu apenas
tenho nada
acho bem
o pl você vai dar
vai lembrar
an você vai ler
ae
[Música]
esse foi o tejo de despedida e se dá uma
vez só na vida
explicar tudo
[Música]
brigados ficarei ou mais escuro do dia
tudo bem senão céu eu achei chegamos tão
perto
mas agora
eu agora por nós
ae você
[Música]
é dada
an e min
que o nosso amor leu a perda
[Música]
su vida
feliz
vale lembrar o pai josé
ah
[Música]
o time o rio na sua boca lê la bella
a subir tal pele
você
vale lembrar
[Música]
porque às vezes é assim que a gente vai
ficar olhando é dessas coisas a gente
vai tocar essas que a gente é mais afins
ambiente
vocês vão gostar também é dessas coisas
que a gente fala de deter o o objetivo
não é ter um propósito que a gente
sempre teve desde o início a nossa
primeira canção de sucesso foi uma coisa
que desafiou a explicação teoria
qualquer coisa ligada à música pop na
época e é engraçado que a gente chegou
numa cena nos anos 80 com bandas tão
fantásticas eletricistas maravilhosa ea
gente tem que fazer a diferença ea gente
resolveu botar o pé dentro do rock
brasileiro com uma canção que fala de um
tema completamente avesso ao sucesso se
a gente pode imaginar que a violência
contra a mulher ea gente escreveu a
canção chamada camila porque ela fala na
vergonha do espírito daquelas marcas nos
olhos uns anos que passava o dia no
verde a às vezes peço a ele que vai
embora e tudo mais é e depois acabou que
essa canção marcou a nossa trajetória né
muitas vezes depois do show naquele
momento em que recebe as pessoas para
autógrafos e conversar
alguém chega espera todo mundo embora em
chega de cantinho e fala olha eu sou uma
camisa na vida real
e essa canção me ajudou a enfrentar
momentos muito complicados
aí a gente vê que valeu a pena ter um
propósito e acreditar em valores como
ensinar de fazer a diferença e que o
rock brasileiro nos anos 80 foi muito
inspirador nesse sentido com cazuza
renato russo
galera dos titãs paralamas e tudo mais
a gente fala dos anos 80 de um jeito
assim com tanto carinho porque a gente
viu isso e essa música que a gente vai
tocar agora ela tem dentro dela um
mistério também que é uma canção que
fala
de uma coisa que aconteceu em julho de
1983 e que até hoje a gente tem a graça
de conseguir renovar o nosso público as
novas gerações cantam e diz respeito a
elas
hoje em 2017
acho que há
de 83
eu sempre esqueço do dia
[Música]
o mais lindo do mês
a gente mal se conhecia
os vivos apenas uma vez
mas foi com o
[Música]
já o velho filme francês não fosse aluno
mateus chega
aquele estilo new ein
quem sabe você
chegar perto de você
[Música]
adolecência base a eu tinha quase 17
ninguém
[Música]
eu não compreendi
fiquei a nesse resultado
na do sob as mãos
pensando em pedir perdão
[Música]
querendo te encontrar
foi então que aconteceu
você me vê o olhar
ele veio em minha direção
sou vindo de seu lar
nesse dia já começou
a nossa história
rick continua até hoje
isso acabar é melhorar
[Música]
adolecência vazia
eu te amo
quase 16
[Música]
eu não
a dona essencial
eu tinha quase 16
eu não to
acho que há
a 80
[Música]
obrigado